[Music]
when I think about how critical internal
and external trusts are to the success
of any business organization I first go
back to how important this principle was
from day one of seal training we talked
about discipline we talked about trust
accountability mental fortitude but I
had a unique experience happened to me
which is pretty rare
during seal training seal training is 18
months long a very very high attrition
rate for my class only about 10%
ultimately graduated of the original
class but the first six months of that
18-month training pipeline is called
bud's which stands for basic underwater
demolition seal and the first three
weeks a buds are leading up to hell week
and those three weeks are no joke either
they're just as bad as hell week but you
get to sleep a couple hours a night but
then hell week is where you're going to
weed out the rest of your class by the
end of hell week eighty percent of your
class is gone the rest will be dropped
or rolled for performance issues or
whatnot but one of the things I write
about in the book was the first time I
learned about you know the pain of loss
and sacrifice and what I was really
going to be experiencing as a member of
the Naval Special Warfare community was
an interesting time because this was
right before 9/11 so it was peacetime
but long story short we were we were in
hell week hell week starts on a Sunday
ends on a Friday afternoon and the great
thing about that Sunday is the class
will report to one of the main
classrooms with only a couple required
items in their possession and we don't
allow them to know when hell week will
commence when breakout starts and it's
pure chaos guys will quit minutes into
breakout and so the anguish the anxiety
is just killing you it's a fascinating
thing to watch not a fascinating thing
to be a part of so that afternoon our
class leader who's the highest ranking
officer in the class he read us one of
the things he done did to motivate us
was to read us the speech the st.
Crispin's Day speech from William
Shakespeare's Henry the fifth and a
great excerpt that many people know from
that speech is we few we happy few we
band of brothers
for he today that sheds his blood with
me
shall be my brother John died four days
later so we are four days into hell week
only about 30 of us left we're in full
gear no fins and an Olympic sized
swimming pool doing relay races and we
were performing an evolution called the
caterpillar race which is not as cute as
it sounds your boat crew of seven guys
will be in the water on your backs in a
line swimming backwards like this except
my legs would be wrapped around the
waist of a guy in front of me his legs
wrapped around the waist of the guy in
front of him and so on and so forth and
even fresh this is a very difficult
evolution to execute properly and keep
your head above water much less beat the
other boat crew to the other side of the
pool everything in hell week is a race
you know four days into hell week you're
just a hallucinating blob of a person so
it's a very it's hard to even keep your
head above water
long story short he obviously those
reports were not released but he had a
massive heart failure and drowned in the
pool next to us and we were all so out
of it nobody knew what was really going
on so about a couple hours later they
assembled us in the classroom and the
commanding officer walks in and he
basically announces that the passing of
our class leader immediately turned over
command to the second highest-ranking
officer in the class did it very
candidly and then next thing he said
I'll never forget he said gentlemen get
used to this feeling that you have right
now this is what it's going to be like
in the teams you were gonna lose
teammates you have to learn to control
your emotions stay focused on your
mission objectives no matter what
happens and trust each other as a team
and of course the the time that's passed
and the emotion of the moment is causing
me to forget his exact words but he
focused on the importance of team trust
and when we think about that from an
organizational standpoint one of the
studies I focus on in the book is by
human capital Institute it was called
building trust 2013 workforce trends
driving high performance and a key data
point there are many but a key data
point that came from that survey was
that employees and this was employees
from all of the world different types of
companies employees in what they defined
is high performance organization so
companies that continue to generate
positive financial returns and steady
growth those employees believe their
leaders managers and even their fellow
peers to be highly trustworthy people so
a culture where people
walk the walk they talked the talk the
leaders words matched their actions
consistently day in and day out they
live the values of the organization both
on and off the battlefield so to speak
and the area that Trust affects most in
the new organization are productivity
and employee engagement and since we all
know that employee engagement is a bit
of a problem in today's workforce
one could theorize that trust is either
not valued or more typically what I've
seen is it's just not properly managed
and measured one of the interesting
evolutions that the individual and the
class goes through in the early stages
of seal training is it goes from an
individual sport where you're trying to
be one of those small percentages of
people that graduate very quickly to a
team sport where you're learning to work
together as a team you're learning to
have that team community that bond and
that shared sense of purpose those
shared values though that team ability
so to speak to put the team before
yourself one of our philosophies in the
SEAL Teams and this starts the first
week of buds through advanced training
through team training is we prioritize
our readiness and that is a team effort
we have to rely on one another for that
readiness because we have to as a team
be able to execute anything at any time
around the world and so readiness is our
number one priority so let's say it's a
training scenario a real-world mission
after we do our after-action review and
assess what went right what we're wrong
how we're going to apply those lessons
learned we focus on team gear then
platoon or troop gear then our gear then
and only then do we focus on ourselves
grabbing some food taking a shower you
are the last priority and it's a
cultural ritual a cultural experience
that really instills that belief of
readiness that belief that the team
comes before you and therefore you start
to proactively take those actions that
will get that result the result being
readiness and of course we can talk
about teamwork and the importance of
that but the most important element of
our culture is is team we referred to as
the Naval Special Warfare community as
the teams we've referred to each other
as team guys that is part of our culture
it is team first and nothing else and
people who don't embody that that
mindset obviously don't make it very far
through training and that applies to any
organization really any relationship
marriage for example is not a 50/50
thing it's a 100 percent 100 percent
thing if you wanted to be successful and
in a business organization that will
thrive and will grow you have that level
of trust that level of of team minded
approach to every single thing you do
people do not stay isolated and siloed
in their in their lane in their bunker
they cross barriers they they
collaborate they build organically
cross-functional teams that allow the
organization to be agile to be dynamic
to be collaborative to be communicative
those are the organizations that are
resilient that grow that maintain a
healthy financial status and it's an
easy correlation to draw between the
SEAL Teams and our importance of
teamwork and Trust to fulfill our vision
just as it is to any organization that
wants to compete and thrive in the 21st
century
[Music]
you